mr. Bruce Campbell yeah there are
certain people at comic-con that all you
have to say is their name and they crowd
goes wild and you are you're like be
original like you're the OG my first
comic-con was in 1950 yes well I do
wanna do you remember how many Comic
Cons you've been to no no I have before
hippies trading comics in the bottom of
the Grand Hotel at that time it only
took about an hour you have become this
character Ashe is somebody who you know
a lot of actors might want to distance
themselves from their iconic original
you know character you have embraced
this guy yeah you want ask you're gonna
choke on it that's it they kept going
you know I was on Burn Notice a number
one show on cable it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter my buddies sam raimi does
these goddamn spider-man movies makes a
billion dollars when's the next Evil
Dead boobie coming it doesn't matter the
other night they wanted it back they
wanted they wanted another movie and
what we try to explain the fans that if
you really want the most carnage and
mayhem for the longest period of time
it's got to be television it really is
and stars is actually the only suitor
who could give you exactly what you
needed ash vs. Evil Dead is an
underrated television show no other
entity or movie if this was another
movie it would have to be r-rated and
you wouldn't get what you want cuz two
out of three Evil Dead movies had no
rating whatsoever so this is what the
savages demand they wouldn't shut up
about it so I'm like okay I'm gonna be
George Lucas and go back and I'm gonna
fix ash and I'm gonna make him into
something new and you can happen for as
many years as you want we got two years
so if you keep showing up we'll give you
as many as you want it doesn't matter
I'm ready to play it all the way through
now until I'm dead I don't care
let's go do it and this truly is this is
a character that you share with the fans
yeah cuz that's just as much of an idiot
as anybody here in the eye I mean
there's no he's not X to the X Navy SEAL
or special ops or MBI he's just kind of
a drunk well no wait a second this year
spoiler ash smokes a little angel dust
on top of it so he's not just a drunk
sir awful he's got quite a repertoire of
bad behavior well that's why I like him
because some heroes are too perfect some
of the hero parts by the way yes Little
Billy here's your medicine now boring I
need a hero who's very flawed and stars
obviously is completely behind you
because they sent wonderful ash for Emmy
materials but ash for any bumper
stickers yeah that worked really well
didn't it however you get to have this
yeah how many of these do you have um
not as many as you think I would
probably not as many as I do I'll put it
to this way my brother has the original
shotgun from Evil Dead well I should
have that right yeah I don't really give
a rat's ass he just likes guns he
doesn't even care about the movie he
sawed it off so it's more badass now it
is yeah so I don't really collect enough
collectors here oh yeah I don't need to
collect crap they'll bring it up to me
I'll sign it for them yeah you get all
those books all the books of the Dead
right well you don't want to sign don't
mess around with that book I am into TJ
Hooker but it's not on the air anymore
you know cuz I'll tell you you watch
shows for different reasons this one was
the hair show uh-huh Adrienne's and
medicine it his hairline starts down
here heather locklear isn't it her hair
is taking off on all sides a Shatner we
were starting fresh with that and it's
about tight police uniforms and skid
marks on the roads you can tell which
take they printed based on how many skid
marks sets of and when it's in HD now it
gets so much better as you can see all
the love you can see all the eight
shadows you know TV shows look really
good now they used to look really shitty
look at TG hooker it's really shitty
looking show Bill Shatner's great in it
and I learned the Shatner power slide
from that show and I did it in the pilot
for ash vs. Evil Dead and a Shatner told
me how to do it I met him in the
greenroom and you know when you meet
these celebrities have a plan by the way
if any of you meet a celebrity have a
have an icebreaker
and don't let it be the obvious one
there was no way I was gonna go to
Shatner and go hey Bill I watched other
Star Trek's when I was it good you're
gonna get nowhere with that an icy
stairs gonna come over it's gonna be a
cold wind blowing in that green room I
went TJ hooker in his eyes lit up nobody
talks about TJ for five years this is
the most it's ever been talked about
Thank You Ryan
what has been your weirdest fan
experiences so far I'm an ordained
minister and I've married a fan couple
and it's legal
and I charge them a lot of money to do
so I am available I have to renew my
license on the Church of eternal
lightness calm something like that but
let me know if you you know need some
help out there well bless you will bless
each other that's how I look at it this
is for Bruce Campbell first of all I
don't know how many books you've written
but I did get a hold of one at a
discount store and I thought it was
about right so keep writing it's very
enjoyable and as soon as I find another
one on sale I'm going
I had a question for you though I am
introducing my children to you slowly
age-appropriate and jack-of-all-trades
we miss it any chance it's coming back
maybe in a different time period old TV
shows age like fish ma'am I appreciate
your interest in that failed show that
was 15 years ago yeah maybe when they
canceled ash vs. Evil Dead which is the
show I currently care about I'll go back
to shows that I have long forgotten
although I will say this about jack of
all trades it has the best opening
credits sequence in the history of
television
my question is for Bruce you have a lot
of interesting fun catchphrases as ash
and the question that I have is how much
is that is ad-libbed and how much is
scripted
that's that who's directing depends on
what's going on if it's Sam Raimi he
gives you a new speech in the middle of
the tape they'll go okay okay now say
this and he'll give you a paragraph and
I the dailies I'm sitting there going oh
mmm-hmm is he ever gonna stop mmm okay
now say this with Sam the scripts or a
rough guide some things just make sense
when you're shooting some things need a
button you know if a demon is saying
I'll swati a sound I'll swallow your
soul
I should swallow this and then he blows
its head on you know I mean it seems
logical most times I like the fact that
Ash trash-talks demons because most in
most horror aspects the demons do all
the trash talking and that's not
acceptable in the ash vs. Evil Dead
world so there's one one phrase that I
know is very powerful
it was the lion give me some sugar baby
the origins of which we were about to
shoot a scene with me and embed Davidson
and Sam went was missing from the set
where is Sam we don't know where he is
and we found him over in a corner
laughing to himself know what you're
gonna say the girl you're gonna say give
me some sugar baby I'm like that's the
stupidest thing I've ever heard of my
life you guys shut up you're gonna say
it you're gonna send he's very adamant
if you question his authority at any
time so I met a guy at one of these fine
events and he says he said thank you for
giving me some sugar baby I mean why are
you thanking me for that he goes well I
was working in China in Beijing and I
had that translated into Mandarin
and I went into a bar and I used it and
I got laid I know there's very powerful
words thank you for your insightful
question
you